Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute was richtig Leckeres und zwar treffen sich Schoko und Vanille auf einem Blech!
Ich hab mir gedacht: "Schokolade mag jeder, Vanille sowieso!"
und deshalb zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal ein super leckeres Rezept, das mir so die letzten Tage einfiel.
Und ich hab ein bisschen rumexperimentiert und möchte euch jetzt mal meinen Teig zeigen
für einen sehr saftigen Schokoladenboden bzw. Schokoladenkuchen.
Und dafür stehe ich jetzt hier schon am Herd denn für dieses Rezept brauchen wir viel Butter.
Ihr wisst ja: Butter ist Geschmacksträger!
Und Butter gebe ich jetzt zuallererst mal zusammen mit Schokolade in meinen Topf und lasse das dann auf mittlerer Stufe schmelzen.
Ihr dürft das nicht zu schnell schmelzen lassen weil sonst die Butter verbrennen würde und im schlimmsten Fall müsst ihr dann alles nochmal neu machen.
Ich hab jetzt übrigens hier Zartbitter und Vollmilch gemischt
weil ich hatte noch 'ne Vollmilch Tafel da und dann hab ich noch ein bisschen Zartbitter genommen aber ihr könnt das nehmen, was ihr möchtet!
Sobald die Butter-Schoko Masse dann geschmolzen ist, füllt ihr sie einmal um in eine große Schüssel
und lasst das am besten nochmal 10min stehen denn jetzt kommen die Eier dazu.
Und wenn das jetzt noch sehr warm wäre, dann hättet ihr Rührei, dann müsstet ihr alles nochmal wegschmeißen
und von neu machen und das wäre mega ärgerlich!
Bei mir ist das jetzt schon runtergekühlt und ich geb jetzt nacheinander die Eier dazu.
Und falls ihr euch fragt wo die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen: hier unten in der Videobeschreibung!
Und da schreibe ich euch dann auch meine Maße und alles, was ihr wissen müsst, hin!
So und jetzt immer schön einzeln die Eier aufschlagen, da nehme ich mir meinen Schneebesen.
Das geht natürlich auch mit der Küchenmaschine aber genauso gut heute auch mit dem Schneebesen.
Und dann immer schön einrühren.
Als nächstes geben wir Zucker dazu und sieben noch die trockenen Zutaten hinein.
Da habe ich Mehl, Backkakao und Backpulver.
Und das Ganze auch einfach nur kurz einrühren und schon ist der Teig fertig!
Jetzt habe ich hier meinen Backrahmen und mein Backblech.
Und am besten nehmt ihr jetzt wenn ihr den Backrahmen einschlagen möchtet -
Der Teig ist jetzt nicht soo flüssig aber es kann sein, dass wirklich mililiterweise was ausläuft.
Das ist auch ganz normal, das muss ich immer wieder betonen!
Besser ist es daher, dass ihr den Backrahmen nochmal in ein bisschen Backpapier einschlagt. Das zeige ich euch jetzt!
Da ist es besser wenn ihr dieses Backpapier verwendet, das man auf einer Rolle bekommt
und nicht was schon zugeschnitten ist weil sonst wird's immer ein bisschen eng.
Und jetzt einfach an den Seiten immer wieder einklappen.
So, dann nochmal glatt verstreichen an der Oberfläche
und jetzt kann er auch schon gebacken werden im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Da braucht er so ungefähr 35min.
Vielleicht auch 36min, macht gerne die Stäbchenprobe!
Und wir machen aber in der Zwischenzeit den Vanillepudding. Bis gleich!
Als nächstes kochen wir einen ganz einfachen Vanillepudding.
Ich weiß, dass viele von euch gerne den Vanillepudding aus der Tüte nehmen.
Da finde ich auch gar nichts Schlimmes dabei aber ich finde persönlich immer, dass man den aufpeppen kann
weil hier ist wirklich nur künstliche Vanille drin und keine richtige Vanille.
Daher koche ich den ganz normal auf und gebe auf jeden Fall Vanilleextrakt mit dazu
weil dann freut man sich später im Anschnitt oder pro Kuchenstück noch mehr wenn man eben so ein Vanillestückchen ergattert.
Also laut Packungsanleitung muss man die Milch erstmal 1/5 trennen und so weiter, ihr kennt das!
Aber ich mach's ehrlicherweise immer so, dass ich Puddingpulver und Zucker direkt in den Topf gebe
und dann erst den Herd einschalte - Natürlich Vanilleextrakt dazu, so! -
dann erst den Herd einschalte und dann so langsam das Ganze aufkoche und das Ganze unter ständigem Rühren!
Sobald der Pudding aufkocht, dickt er auch schon ein
und an der Stelle einfach direkt vom Herd ziehen und durch ein Sieb in eine Schüssel geben.
Das Wichtige ist jetzt hierbei, dass ihr den Pudding direkt an der Oberfläche mit Frischhaltefolie ähm...abdeckt
damit keine Haut entsteht.
Und falls ihr jetzt doch tatsächlich kein Puddingpulver da haben solltet, geht auch Speisestärke
aber das ist ein Fall für die Infobox! Da schreibe ich euch solche Dinge z.B. auch schön fein säuberlich auf.
Und jetzt warten wir nur noch bis unser Pudding auskühlt, wir warten bis der Boden abkühlt und dann geht's weiter!
So, den abgekühlten Boden gebe ich dann auf meine Schieferplatte
und entferne den Backrahmen. Das mache ich am liebsten mit meinem Backformlöser, dann reiße ich mir da die Seiten auch nicht auf.
Und jetzt geht's eigentlich schon weiter mit dem Befüllen!
Und dafür nehmen wir uns jetzt unseren abgekühlten Pudding.
Einmal die Frischhaltefolie entfernen und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach nur einen Schneebesen.
Das geht natürlich auch wieder mit der Küchenmaschine
aber ich rühre jetzt einfach ganz kräftig mit dem Schneebesen, so ungefähr 1min lang
und dann wird das Ganze so ein bisschen.. das verändert so ein bisschen die Konsistenz!
So, als nächstes nehme ich mir hier eine Tülle und jetzt steche ich mir hier ein paar Löcher aus
Und auch nicht ganz bis zum Boden gehen!
So und jetzt geben wir den "Deckel" wieder drauf damit wir das so schön verstecken.
Und danach könnt ihr euch überlegen: Macht ihr da noch 'ne Glasur drauf oder macht ihr's so wie ich?
Weil ich möchte es so einfach wie möglich halten. Ich mach da einfach nur Puderzucker drauf und das reicht mir.
Und dann bin ich gespannt auf den Anschnitt!
So, das ist jetzt der fertige Kuchen und der sieht äußerlich relativ unspektakulär aus.
Und wenn man ihn dann anschneidet, denkt man sich so: "Uiuiui, was ist da drin denn los?"
Ich mag solche Kuchen!
Einfach, kann jeder nachmachen, man braucht nichts spezielles, besonderes oder sonstwas
und innen hat er noch so richtig Pfiff!
Ich mag das. Ich mag das Rezept, ich find's toll!
Also wenn ihr das Ganze nachmachen möchtet, dann - Du brauchst nicht lachen! -
dann guckt in die Infobox, da schreibe ich euch nochmal alles ganz genau hin.
Und ansonsten gehen Hamza und ich rüber zu unserem Tasty Table, dort werden wir nämlich probieren.
Und ja, folgt uns einfach!
[Kiki] So Hamza, du hast Platz genommen am Tasty Table!
[Hamza] ..Tasty Table!
[Kiki] Ich hab mal 'ne Frage: Welchen findest du schöner, den oder den?
[Hamza] Eindeutig den!
[Kiki] Ich hab mir nämlich grad noch überlegt: Irgendwie gefiel mir das nicht so..
[Kiki] ...und dann hab ich da den restlichen Kuchenteig obendrüber gekrümelt
[Hamza] Kann es sein, dass du auch da ein bisschen mehr Vanille reingehauen hast?
[Kiki] Ich hab auch mit dem Vanillepudding hier ein bisschen mehr übertrieben also geizt nicht mit dem Vanillepudding!
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Ich find's lecker!
[Hamza] Es ist halt ein einfacher Geschmack, ne? Es ist ein Schokokuchen mit Vanille.
[Kiki] Ja, also irgendwie das, was jeder mag!
[Hamza] Genau. Also man kann jetzt nicht sagen: "Boah, da treffen so viele Komponenten zusammen, dies das!"
[Hamza] Das ist ein einfach Kuchen, den glaub ich jeder lieben wird und jeder mögen wird..
[Hamza] ..weil's halt so einfach auch schmeckt! Vanillepudding und Schokokuchen! Was gibt's besseres?
[Hamza] Einfach und schnell auch vor allem, ne?
[Kiki] Hast du gut gesagt! Hast du gut gesagt Hamza!
[Hamza] Also der Boden ist heftig! Also der Kuchen an sich ist sehr, sehr lecker, sehr saftig!
[Kiki] Und da kommt die Überraschung! Jetzt sieht man's mehr!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall!
[Kiki] Und das ist das, was dann eure Gäste sehen!
[Kiki] Die sagen sich so: "Boaah der sah so unscheinbar aus und dann kommt sowas bei raus!"
[Hamza] ..das raus. Ja, das sieht echt cool aus. Also dieser Wow-Effekt ist auf jeden Fall drin!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Überraschungskuchen!
[Kiki] Also das Ding ist, dass ihr diesen Schokoteig an sich ja auch so machen könnt!
[Kiki] Das ist dann einfach ein mega mega saftiger Schokoladenkuchen!
[Kiki] Und ja, probiert's einfach mal aus! Auf jeden Fall richtig lecker!
[Kiki] Also an sich ist der Schokoteig schon mega gut und dann noch mit der Vanille..
[Kiki] Ist echt einer meiner Top-Favoriten wenn's um normale, schnelle Kuchen geht!
[Hamza] Aber auch was Besonderes! Also es ist schon was Besonderes mit der Vanille.
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Kiki] Und man muss sagen: Also der zweite Kuchen, den ich gemacht hab, der ist jetzt noch lauwarm und das schmeckt richtig gut!
[Kiki] Probiert das ruhig mal aus! Kalt schmeckt er mit Sicherheit auch.
[Kiki] Ansonsten deckt ihn immer schön ab, dann bleibt er auch schön saftig.
[Kiki] Und dann würden wir uns einfach mal verabschieden!
[Hamza] Peace and out!
[Kiki] Tschüüss!